[Musica]
[Applauso]
la città tenace e il titolo di un
articolo che scrisse un urbanista
americano melvin weber nel 1996
insegnava all'università della
california berkeley e scrisse questo
articolo in cui sosteneva il seguente
argomento e cioè
la il cambiamento all'avanzamento
tecnologico permette comunicazioni a
distanza sempre più efficienti ed
economiche e tuttavia una parte
consistente
importante delle nostre vite e ancora
condizionata utilmente condizionata
dalla relazione di prossimità la
relazione di prossimità con coni servizi
con con il lavoro con i servizi
scolastici con la con i servizi
culturali con con gli spazi dedicati al
tempo libero e alla socialità e alle
relazioni con gli altri con gli amici
con i parenti dunque quello di cui noi
abbiamo bisogno è importante per noi e
l'accessibilità ai servizi e agli altri
alle persone
e in questo dice melvin weber nola la
possibilità che offre la città di avere
accessibilità le persone ai servizi
costituisce questa la condizione urbana
e ne dà conto della sua tenacia perché
appunto malgrado il cambiamento
tecnologico gli avanzamenti che sfidano
il
e rendono quasi obsoleto la condizione
urbana tuttavia la città resiste questo
tipo di considerazione che a me è sempre
sembrata molto interessante ovviamente
mia mi è tornata in mente credo come a
molti di noi nel momento del primo
lockdown quando abbiamo visto e credo a
tutti abbiamo un po temuto il fatto che
la città scomparisse e l'abbiamo vista
dalla finestra popolarsi anche di attori
non umani e quello che ad un certo punto
abbiamo cominciato a temere che
deperisse no il carattere della città
nel senso che ci trovassimo in una
condizione nella quale era impossibile
anzi eravamo impossibilitati a
avvicinarci agli altri appunto a
frequentare ad essere a poter esercitare
l'accessibilità ai servizi alle altre
persone dovevamo rispettare il
distanziamento sociale
e e dunque ad un certo punto abbiamo
temuto che che il carattere che questa
condizione urbana la tenacia della città
potessimo potessimo perderla e
ovviamente il lock down ha minato ha
inciso profondamente anche sulla diciamo
sulla corporeità sull'aspetto anche
corporeo della nostra relazione con gli
altri e appunto con la città ha limitato
il tatto no è condizionato anche il
contatto con gli altri la possibilità di
assembrarsi di essere vicini prossimi
agli altri
e dunque ad un certo punto abbiamo detto
ma forse conviene anche
ci hanno costretti a farlo e tutto
sommato alcuni hanno cominciato a dire
vabbè ma si può anche stare in casa e in
casa lavorare studiare collegarsi agli
altri con i nostri device tecnologici
anche a molta distanza perfino fare un
po di sport non fare un po di diciamo di
movimento di palestra nella in casa e
per molti di noi è stato vero ma non per
tutti perché provate a farlo in
condizioni di agio abitando in sei in un
bilocale no dovendo vivere una domestici
ta coatta
come gli anziani nelle rsa o
immigrati nei centri di accoglienza e
dunque ad un certo punto qualcuno ha
cominciato a dire guardate che il
teorema della casa mondo in quella cosa
per cui va bene se sta in casa va bene
lo stesso e va bene lo stesso per tutti
non è così vero non è così vero per
tutti
e quindi quindi siamo tornati a
interrogarci sulla città siamo tornati a
interrogarci sulla città e abbiamo visto
anche effetti mente la il nostro la
condizione urbana deperire ma abbiamo
anche capito con una certa chiarezza mi
pare che in particolare hanno subito
l'attacco dei covi del 19 in particolare
i luoghi i posti specializzati della
città hanno particolarmente sofferto e
si sono svuotate le torri monofunzionali
degli uffici quelli in cui c'è il
quartier generale delle grandi aziende
le downtown il che peraltro sono
ospitate nel tipo edilizio privo di
ventilazione naturale che ovviamente
gov.it 19 predilige e dunque non abbiamo
erano vuoti si sono svuotati
improvvisamente però anche altri luoghi
specializzati certamente no come i
cinema i teatri le palestre posti come
questo quindi ad un certo punto ci siamo
detti ma stiamo smarrendo i luoghi cioè
la città come luogo l'abbiamo persa la
stiamo perdendo io qui ho un punto che
vorrei sottolinearlo perché non sono
certissimo luogo è una parola densa una
parola molto
insomma che userei con una certa
parsimonia perché vuol dire che ci sono
dei posti nel mondo nella città che
hanno significati condivisi che hanno
incorporano simbologie comuni c'è un
genio dei luoghi lo dicevano i latini
e quindi i luoghi richiamano il sacro
richiamano qualcosa anche di più potente
che forse non è stato povod 19 a
intaccare c'è un passo molto bello
ricordato in un libro che si chiama il
libro dei luoghi scritto da un grande
urbanistica giovanni ferraro e che
ricorda come plutarco a un certo punto
ct l'incontro fra ip man ide un
divinatore del vii secolo avanti cristo
che si che giunge ad adelphi all'oracolo
di delfi e rivolge una domanda
all'oracolo e dice ma in che cosa
consiste la sacralità di questo luogo se
non era sacro quello noi l'ombelico del
mondo e il l'oracolo gli risponde né
della terra esiste un centrone del mare
e se esiste è noto agli dei ma celato
agli uomini epimenide considera questa
risposta sconcertante e forse anche noi
ancora oggi dopo un bel po di tempo
continuiamo a ritenere la sconcertante
perché perché ci dice una cosa è una
cosa un po pesante e cioè che sei luoghi
esistono sono celati agli uomini li
conoscono gli dei e noi invece siamo
dobbiamo vivere nel mondo nello spazio
nei posti in maniera mi vien da dire un
po più laica forse
infatti peraltro se abbiamo in mente
anche i monoteismi hanno una relazione
con i luoghi un po complicata no perché
lo elohim si presenta al suo popolo nel
deserto libico in g1 alleanze dunque in
un posto che è esattamente uno luogo è
anche il dio cristiano forse vive il
mondo no non è non lo riconosci presente
in alcuni più luoghi specifici certo la
chiesa è un luogo sacro
ma prima di essere una chiesa prima di
essere una cosa che non è poesia cioè
una comunità di pratiche allora il punto
è se i luoghi sono occultati alla
conoscenza della delle persone che cos'è
che anche da questo punto di vista covip
19 ci ha detto ci sta dicendo ad esempio
ci ha detto che durante la pandemia ci
sono state in molte città
io vivo a milano anche delle iniziative
interessanti molto interessanti molto
importanti come le ceste sospese la foto
nella regalata francesca rendano che una
mia amica che nel quartiere di dergano a
milano a una libreria che si chiama
musca ed è stata insieme ad altri
animatrice di questa iniziativa calare
una cesta e lasciare qualcosa per
qualcuno chi può di a chi ha bisogno
prenda io ho l'impressione che questo
tipo di pratica in quel momento sia
stato una ricostruzione di un luogo in
cui delle forme di vita
no potrebbe spotx remo dire si
incontrano in compresenza si scambiano
qualcosa non necessariamente costruendo
una comunità un luogo sacro ma
semplicemente dicendo c'è qualcosa che
possiamo scambiarci una compresenza
fra diversi in quel caso fra sconosciuti
che hanno fatto un luogo hanno riempito
a mio avviso di di un significato molto
denso quello spazio quello spazio della
cesta sotto il balcone di quella casa e
allora su questo vorrei concludere
provando a dare qualche lo so se qualche
indicazione diciamo sì qualche
prospettiva su come lavorare oggi anche
a causa di co lead 19 cioè sulla base di
quello che covip 19 ci ha insegnato
sulla tenacia della città la prima è la
prima indicazione che mi viene in mente
è lo spazio della città è uno spazio
interessante per fare in maniera utile
forse anche più interessante
rispondere diciamo a domande a bisogni
anche ad aspirazioni sociali per esempio
per praticare lo sport nella città
questo non è sostitutivo dell'impianto
dedicato cioè della della palestra però
si può fare anche movimento nella città
come 19 per esempio ci ha insegnato una
cosa che forse sapevamo già bene prima
ma lì è stata eclatante che anche la
medicina quando si fa territoriale e più
efficaci i sistemi sanitari
esclusivamente basati sulla presenza di
strutture specializzate hanno resistito
molto peggio di quelli viceversa che
disponevano di una medicina di una rete
di presidi di medicina territoriale
diffusi perché hanno permesso efficiente
di rallentare l'arrivo dei casi di covip
verso i centri specializzati e forse di
destinare soltanto agli ospedali i casi
più gravi
dunque anche la medicina quando si fa
territoriale interessante ed è utile a
trattare domande bisogni sociali e poi
la scuola la scuola oggi sappiamo che si
fa che bisogna fare la scuola fuori
dalla scuola
abbiamo dovuto fare anche in parte e
sperimentare proseguire e
sperimentazioni già presenti però non
dobbiamo farla credo con l'idea di
replicare fuori dalla scuola facendo
outdoor education come si dice la stessa
lo stesso modello dell'indoor cose
portiamo fuori i banchi e la cattedra e
rifacciamo lo stesso setting dentro al
parco no probabilmente la cosa
interessante anzi senz'altro la cosa
interessante utilizzare la città per la
sua capacità educante per la sua
capacità di costruire solo dico pure io
no comunità educanti lo dico pure io nel
senso che usa un altra parola un po
pesante come comunità dopo quella di
luogo però insomma di utilizzare la
città come un corpo insegnante non
soltanto l'ambiente lo spazio il
contenitore dove dove fare istruzione la
seconda indicazione che ci ha dato covi
di 19 anche questo non ci voleva il covi
da capirlo è però lì è stato eclatante
appunto
oggi siamo ancora in una condizione
nella quale possiamo pensare che la bit
abili la vita nello spazio delle città è
riservato soltanto agli uomini cioè al
genere umano non siamo perfettamente
coscienti che viviamo abbiamo bisogno di
costruire qualcuno dice dei collettivi
di umani e non umani dentro la città noi
sapere che questo è il destino che c'è
già oggi bruno latour filosofo della
scienza dice nel nuovo regime climatico
sta succedendo qualcosa di impensabile
la storia umana sta diventando lenta e
la storia naturale è diventata
tumultuosa lo vediamo nei fenomeni che
che ci capitano e dunque abbiamo bisogno
oggi di ripensare il nostro la nostra
vita nella città la tenacia della città
come un qualcosa che si esercita in un
continuum natura cultura la foto è la
foto di un concerto bellissimo di
pianoforte nei campi di grano a
chiaravalle a milano alle 6 del mattino
all'alba è solo evocativo di questa cosa
ovviamente la foto
avevamo visto io e mia moglie la foto è
sua di questo straordinario concerto a
cui avevamo assistito e infine l'ultima
indicazione più progettuale un po da
urbanista forse è quella di curare lo
spazio pubblico lo spazio pubblico è lo
spazio collettivo lo spazio dove
possiamo andare tutti nella città
e frequentarlo con le nostre pratiche
diverse chi si siede scrive chi incontra
un amico chi parla chi chi fa jogging il
fava di corsa chi semplicemente
passeggia fa il flaneur siamo in francia
a bordo viene bene pure la flanery me
l'ha mandato un amico si chiama mio
amico architetto filibeck è che quando
sapeva che devo fare questa cosa ha
detto ecco allora se hai bisogno di
qualche foto di spazi pubblici ti mando
questo lungo la garon
allora importante lo il progetto dello
spazio pubblico ed è importante
soprattutto
mantenere per per rinvigorire
salvaguardare e sviluppare la tenacia
della città mantenere e appunto
sviluppare e qualificare la elemento
poroso percorribile aperto della città
un'accoglienza dentro lo spazio pubblico
un'abitabilità dentro lo spazio pubblico
che accolga e sia in grado di accomodare
le iper diversità che nella città viva
di a viva dio vivono
e allora se è così io credo che l'ultima
considerazione che vorrei fare per
chiudere che
allestire la città una città porosa
percorribile aperta dove possiamo
abitare con agio
che vuol dire io spero di averlo
chiarito
mantenere e sviluppare il carattere
tenace della città la sua condizione
urbana del che è quella che è che la
rende grande interessante viverci beh
anche l'effetto che torna su di noi
questa cosa ci ritorna c'è una
abitabilità della città per cui la città
è anche un po come dire ci torna in
dieci e ci abita cc risponde alle nostre
sollecitazioni
e allora come diceva qualcuno
ci si trova in compagnia sotto i portici
del centro e all'uscita del metrò per
guardarci dentro la città serve anche a
riguardarsi con i suoi occhi
grazie
[Applauso]